there's a lot of debate about how
professional runners should be left for
the elite and then on the other side
professional runners should just be
anyone who's making a living through
running and I fit squarely in neither of
those category
[Music]
I would not describe myself as a
professional runner running for me is is
for me all day at work you have this
voice in your head like you don't dress
nice enough and I'm executive enough
whatever it is but running for the one
thing where I can be like yeah I can run
across the state why not try you know
goal for me is to be the fastest known
woman to run across California from
North Lake Tahoe to Stinson Beach
planning take 10 days but maybe we'll go
even faster than that two of my friends
we're just like yeah I'll support you
doing this thing we have a base plan I'm
going to run every day and then one
personal drive bag and one person over
on must meet we're really just gonna see
what happened it could be that I'm like
sitting here doing the interview and in
five days those three sitting on the
side of the road being like don't know
why every year like I need to run across
my state or do my first ultra marathon
or whatever it is it's just something
that I do
[Music]
so there's definitely been periods in my
life where I feel lonely even when
you're like surrounded by people like at
work in an office or something but I'm
on the trail by myself yeah I don't feel
alone I mean that's why I run there was
magic in the middle days because when
you start your third marathon in a row
and you have legs
you're like my body is amazing this is
crazy
today we ran from a Robinson flat into a
little bit caught for sale might eat
builders just my legs are tired now a
few blisters so seems still good run no
bad pain yet but I'm really excited
about that
after this planning to have cooldown
loss few miles and then I'm really
hoping my friends will want to go to
brunch with me and give me a nice back
I know how much running has given me and
I want other women to have that when
they look on the starting line they
don't see people that look like them
whether that's based on gender identity
racial identity different body types so
to the degree that I can show up and
help change that I want to on the sixth
day I was like I don't know about this I
might not have legs i Ron maybe like
twenty two miles and all of a sudden
like my legs were not running anymore
first my butt gave out and then like my
quads and it was just kind of like my
legs were going through the remaining
like muscles that were left that was a
moment for me because I don't think
mentally I was in it to walk it I
remember in my head being like this is
going to be any like interesting like
we'll see what my body has tomorrow
[Music]
on the seventh day think Iran maybe like
four miles and then it was just this
like brutal long eight or nine hour day
like walking and it was very painful to
run I didn't want to do anything that
would make it so I couldn't run a few
weeks later I made it basically today
which is cool oh yeah I know
even after walking the whole day I can't
really move my legs
please August 7th my birthday and we're
we stopped in Fairfield short of our
goal of course it's disappointing but as
Lexie Papa says good thing I didn't
accomplish all my goals yet and what
would I do tomorrow I wanted to run and
I could have accomplished this goal if I
like walked a little and ran a little
but I wanted to run I mean I'm a middle
of the Packer who ran 175 miles in one
week I wanted to run across California
and in doing that I found out how far I
could go if that's the metric then it
was a success
[Music]